see that you also get the guys that
complain that oh my day she didn't know
what she was doing in bed and then now
he started cheating five years down the
line because she's so dead and also no
wait no wait no wait no I've heard the
guy say we actually weren't sexually
compatible that's the reason why because
he was probably too much of a freak most
girls can't have good sex seriously gosh
most girls are not good at six how did
you know
[Laughter]
um
no honestly most girls just take wood
let's be real like but if it's your
partner would you not teach them and
would you not
would you like not like growth like as
in you're teaching her what you like
she's teaching you what she likes of
course it's contextual
um I don't think you can be the partner
and not expect her to lack certain
things but then that's what I'm saying
to certain guys they're just overly
freaky because most men are very simple
to please just block them it's true but
guys would prefer a girl they could
teach yeah versus because if she's
coming in a freak he's like where did
you
learned
you're so funny I have this discussion
about my Mo cousins my brothers I feel
like every guy says listen I'll be right
Men Are from Mars Women Are from Venus
one of my favorite books men are so
simple well what you like say peace of
mind when they don't want to talk just
leave them he will come back when he's
ready and I feel like because we're so
emotional and erratic sometimes it's
like you know how men are quite logical
when you call your man of a problem we
just want to hear um is it is it is that
the reality most times we're not doing
well because of our nature we don't we
try in our heads we're like like me me
for example I feel like I can be very
peaceful I can be very understanding but
there are times in the month where I'm
not I'm just not having it because of my
I don't know maybe I can blame it on the
hormones or or that day is just not the
day or I'm in my head about something
that he's done as much as I want to be
peaceful I might not be peaceful that
day and so I feel like somebody then it
wouldn't be your character
I'm not saying that it's it's good that
I'm like that I know that it can be a
problem but relationships are never
perfect you know what I mean I could
control that at work right I I can and
the thing is I do control it in my
relationship as much as I can there's no
relationship that doesn't have fights or
arguments you know what I mean so but
sometimes you go from zero to 100 and
you know you've as long as you
acknowledge you've done it and you're
able to apologize and accept
accountability you try and change that's
quite interesting because like um Phil
said you can eat for most women you can
stay quiet at work but at home you Let
it Loose like why is that I mean you
have to communicate okay with someone
why does your boss have more power than
you it depends on what you call it and
if some women are mad and It's Shouting
and it's throwing plates I mean we see
it on social media we see movies and
stuff like you know some women do throw
things around the name of Jordans
smashing phones smashing cars we see
that yeah but a lot of women are not
doing that and also can I say something
before you got with that women I'm gonna
lie you should have seen her in all her
Seasons when I say Seasons I mean how
she's reacting to like how she's talking
when she don't know that you're watching
how she's dealing with a certain
situations I understand some women are
tapped some men are tapped but I also
feel like if you're getting with a woman
you should try and see her you won't
always see it though you you won't even
I think I agree no I feel like you can
see everyone in their Seasons you just
have to I think in modern generation a
lot of us lack self-awareness 100 yeah
so and I think that is more
um more women lack self-awareness for
that I'm gonna say that just because
of the situation we're talking about how
prevalent are they you don't really see
men going out there and doing Mad stuff
like that you see women doing that more
so but speak on it if you didn't
disagree I agree with you it's shown
it's shown that's what I was gonna say
it's promoted to perpetuate to
perpetuate it further and to empower
people who don't have the understanding
so for me it's not about me but being
self-reflective is a part of day-to-day
Life as a partner to somebody else if
you can't reflect on your own behaviors
you shouldn't be on in a relationship
what do you mean by self-reflective what
actionable items is that so if for
example you have a disagreement with
your partner okay you should be able to
communicate how how that came about what
because men they use less words yeah
they don't want to hear a whole load of
talking let's be honest they just want
to get straight to the point what can I
do to be a better partner to you in this
situation communicating that to your
partner because you're the you're the
second in command if you want to say
your your man is a representation of you
and you are a representation of your man
when he's not around and when he's
around obviously do you think that's
what men want
well I don't do you think they want like
constant communication
well I will say I don't know what men
want but I will ask them I don't assume
anything I'm going to ask you every man
every man is different what say for
example what Devonte requires and what's
your name
Phil what Phil requires maybe totally
different spectrums you know Phil's
married to his wife she's got maybe not
I don't know but maybe she's got six
attributes of maybe the 10 attributes he
really loves and that is good enough and
he can work on that but if you don't if
you're not self-reflective as a as a
woman and a man together
I think I think we may not have to be
self-aware in today's society because
because of the accountability element so
yeah there is no impetus throughout your
life as you're growing older for you to
have to be self-reflective and
self-aware because especially if you're
attractive especially if you're
attractive most men give you everything
you want you can get there's no need
there's no need for you to have to think
okay how do I behave in this context of
that context I think that comes with
maturity give an example of talking to a
girl and she's very attractive and I
told her most of the girls around you
are with you because you're pretty and
most of the guys that chat you just want
to [__] you but to her she just thought
this is all everybody loves me everybody
loves me so at what point in her life
does she realize that she's being used
and by the time she's able to realize by
when she's mature she's already beat out
by Bare man so where's her value
why do women always think they're tans
in my life had a man say I'm a 10. you
know man I'm honest I feel like if my
like if I don't look nice my diaphragm
will say you don't look nice I change
that I go oh girl you look so cute so I
feel like men accept the reality and
they're not gonna lie to you you have to
you might not you sorry a person X might
be really minus one however her
girlfriends because of mental health and
like a lot of things they might just be
like you're really beautiful right now
but that goes that goes back to the
point that women don't face reality like
the women who say that their tens don't
really believe they are anyway when you
when you see how they behave they don't
behave like they believe their terms
they're just saying it because of what
they can get but the point is they can
go out in society and be delusional yeah
like and that's that's normal for women
and women women are built out of every
single bed decision we make can I just
can I just say about the 10 business
most of the women that lie to their
friends and say their friend is a 10
knowing she's a free Allah sorry
that happens because it allows those
women who also feel that they're a three
and a four yeah or maybe a five or a six
feel bolstered up in that group do you
understand feel like the beautiful
friend like oh yeah girl you look good
but when you go out like your friends
looking a bit tacky and you feel a bit
more attractive
that's a dynamic in in play so they're
more desirable to mend it's indirect is
it insulting for a woman to be called
average
if it's the reality honestly if you're
average your personality might be like
out of this world but the reality is to
the human eye or to whoever's telling
you your average that's their opinion I
don't think there's anything wrong with
preference you might be um like 10 out
of 10 to me you might be five out of ten
someone else it's just and you can't but
that's a female like you're not a 10 out
of 10 to anyone if you're ever talking
but then you can't take what someone
else says if you are averages if you
know your average go and work on
yourself or believe in your average
but I'm saying most people are average
so like oftentimes if I tell a girl
she's average they get defensive they're
mad because it has a negative
connotation but just tell them fix up
and use your brains average what is a
three what's the ten let's clarify them
okay ten is perfect oh yeah what other
what are the things that make people
these rankings that's what I was talking
about like women's primary value to the
world is your looks that's the most like
valuable asset that you can see every
year when they show the most handsome
man exactly and I'll just be like he's
all right I don't think he's all that
but scientifically when you go out and
ask people yeah because you find 80 of
men unattractive that's why you think
that no I think no it's not right it's
just not my type that's why like that's
why you could find the most handsome man
on the planet
let me finish you you keep interrupting
me stop and you could find a guy in the
top five percent of of male handsome and
you still find him man he's all right
and like that's that's women that's true
women do we do let's be real we do it no
we're talking someone's so nicely she
might do even when you see someone with
their boyfriend you'll be like um I'll
tell him he's nice no no no you see
someone with that boy so you don't think
the boyfriend's mind no I'm saying if I
think someone's nice I believe no no if
you don't think someone's boyfriend is
nice no It's the reaction what's your
reaction at least he treats you nice
to answer your question I say eight to
ten means you can get a modeling
contract eight is it you're the
prettiest girl in a small town nine
means you're going to Hollywood based on
your looks alone 10 is damn near Pro
perfect seven I go off of Kevin Samuel's
scale so I don't do sevens because
people are either models or they're cute
pretty five is normal six is cute below
that
okay
but yeah that's that's how so but a lot
like on Tick Tock the other day
um
I I got banned but before I got banned I
commented on a girl because she was
going off on my things and I just said
another average looking girl coping oh
man because she was
because she she was mad because I was
saying men prefer younger women it's
just true it's not fun I don't enjoy
that I'm getting you know I'm 25 I'm
gonna be 26 in November I don't enjoy
that but it's just true and if you're
average looking at 30 you're below
average
but you know she but like that's in it
but do you see everyone's silent because
that's an insult but it should be it's
not it wasn't until it's the insults
even if I said average looking guy no
one really yeah
a man once I agree with you but yeah
yeah it's so crazy because it's like men
want maybe what's younger than them
maybe because you're bendable you're
movable is that you're teachable whereas
when you're older you're probably more
stuck in your ways and also you're
probably prettier because you're younger
unless you just don't look your age that
shouldn't be the case people people do
lie because if if you walk around you
believe you're 10 and you're like I'm a
10 I'm a 10. people are gonna shut you
down and say no you're not but if you go
around saying I'm a two they would also
try and pump you up and say no you're
not even the two you're five
most people don't want to be honest
about what they really think because
they don't want to hurt feelings but I
think if women really got that pushback
there wouldn't be so many claiming their
towns that's true so I don't think I
think that's true but if a man goes on
social media and he says I'm a town of
my town I'm a town I swear to God women
will be the first ones even even you
this is the most handsome man on the
planet for a magazine
and your first comment is he's all right
and it's I'm no hate to you it's just
part of like women but my thing is yeah
we're not organizing attractive is
attractive that's my point do you know
what I think it is as well some most for
women's I feel for me let me speak